oil rigs are used to drill new wells and
when oil prices dropped last year they
started shutting down at an
unprecedented rate more than a third of
us rigs have been taken offline in just
three months it makes sense that if
Riggs lead to new wells then fewer rigs
should lead to less oil right not
necessarily so far oil production hasn't
taken a hit in fact it's still going up
according to US Energy forecast the US
will pump almost eight percent more oil
this year levels not seen since 1972 so
rig counts are down but oil production
is up why here are three main reasons
number one efficiency it's mostly older
less efficient rigs that are being taken
offline newer machines including
horizontal rigs used in fracking are
doing better and oil drillers are
focusing their remaining rigs on regions
that crank out the most oil squeezing
more oil from fewer rigs number 2 sunk
costs new wells can cost 12 million to
drill oil companies pay that fee upfront
and it takes years to make that money
back for the most part it doesn't make
financial sense to stop pumping from
wells that have already been drill so
the pumping continues number 3 oil
prices the price of crude has dropped by
about fifty percent since June but at
around fifty dollars a barrel many
shells are still profitable shale wells
crank out a lot of oil for about 18
months rigs only collapse in the last
few months so there's a lag there and
production hasn't caught it yet
in the meantime American drillers are
pumping oil so fast they're running out
of places to stash it storage tanks that
hold us oil are at the highest levels in
at least 80 years the slowdown may be
coming but it's not here yet